on this episode I invite tougher max to
jam with me
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 207 of
the ask gary vee show I'm excited we got
a guest
I'll let this wonderful man introduced
himself I know a lot of you know who he
is it's post Memorial Day but first and
foremost more importantly than anything
else I want to give a huge shout out to
my baby daughter Misha happy seventh
birthday I will be running out of here
in a second to go see at school do the
cupcake thing very excited I love you
with all my heart speaking about love
India I got to see you it does have you
been you've been like you've been away
forever I feel I feel like I haven't
seen you in years
I wear the West Coast or something no I
was I was in DC for one night on
Thursday that was cool that was good
time yeah yeah I went to see a movie at
the White House was a month it was
awesome yoshiwo president no he was out
of town he let me know that before time
yeah they let you know yeah it's also
going on good got the question I have
the question you ready for sure I'm
ready for the show all right let's go
two more guests my friend why don't you
tell the Vayner nation uh actually I
will need to sell it while you do this
part um who you are and what you're up
to
all right so my name is Tucker max I
wrote a book called I hope his/her beer
and I would spend like half a decade on
the bicylist and it was a movie made
about it whatever and now I have a
company called book in a box that's
thinking about we turn ideas in the
books so like if you have an idea for a
book and you don't want to sit at a
computer for a year typing it out we
have a process where we interview you we
position the ideas structure it create
an outline get everything in the
interview process almost like a version
of ghost writing which then allows the
book to be created no so ghost writing
is like if you're hiring ghostwriter
you're hiring someone to write their
version of your ideas into book and then
you're paying them so you can put your
name on it
yes with us our process doesn't work if
you don't know exactly what you're
talking about because it's all your own
content we're adding nothing to it we
just have a very funnel second algorithm
but a structured process where great
writers and editors are guiding you
through it asking questions so it feels
like magic to you all you're doing is
talk
about what you already know you know
twitter about this this is how actually
i tell ya i basically just like talk and
get interviewed by staff and just like
to me like all and then i I don't know
if in your world this works and then I
basically all the editing that I do is
always like wait a my dream scenario is
that a she helps me structure for sure
like the thought of like one continuous
run book there I'd have one long run-on
sentence or semi look and two grammar
but and then but they're like any word
scares it like I'm always petrified like
do I even say that would I say that word
like I'm really just the transcription
of the conversation is that we don't do
transcription it's more we interview and
then because spoken word is different
than written on 10% so once we've got it
structured in the interview the job of
the editor is the interview you get
everything out of your head and then
once it's transcribed to can translate
that into written and this happened was
this a scenario where where you know
it's fun even this is the first time
we're meeting right yeah which is crazy
because we hear some little friend
humming friends so what I know from afar
is you know did I assume what happened
was your this actually you know what
let's take it there for a second like
this book is this was a smash head my
first one right and like you definitely
didn't think that's what was gonna
happen first how did you even get to the
point of writing that first one man it's
kind of find you write a book I started
well I went to law school my friends and
I all went to different cities to work
okay
and I got few of our you know law school
friends yeah right okay all uh all law
school friends I got fired on Kentucky
like that total be Fe Kentucky no other
Kentucky yeah no you don't play you love
it because you didn't grow up there it's
a different place okay it's a terrible
place yeah like there's a reason
everyone weeds not it so middle nowhere
Kentucky and then we're and then where
did you go to school uh University of
Chicago from your grad
than Duke for law school president no
more Kentucky twice that school is easy
once you learn how to hack this is I've
never figured that part out okay and so
you go and do that and so you think
you're gonna be a lawyer yeah that's
like what's up mmm and then I got five
hundred like for nowhere Kentucky that
was like holy [ __ ] you made it
yeah sort of I came from a family that
they weren't really rich but pretty
well-known and a lot in the area yeah
like my grandfather was a doctor my mom
was one of the first women to ever go
sorry our grandmother was one of the
first women to ever graduate from the
University of Kentucky so I came from a
family of achievers like my
great-great-great grandfather was a u.s.
senator like you know maybe four greats
way far back so you needed this book to
get into the game exactly okay so so you
go you you go to law school you can get
some buddies you guys go to different
places where do you go
what sir I've moved I moved to Silicon
Valley to Mountain View I was working
for a firm called Fenwick and West I
know that yeah right important for some
of my deals there you go well they fired
me amazing and I deserved it though
you're on Vicks I deserve to be fired
because I got well so the reason I
thought I got fired was I got super
drunk at this big law firm event yeah
and I there's like an auction and I grab
the mic and I basically my cradle that
the other people who were bidding on me
fasting and it was really funny but it
was kind of mildly inappropriate but not
it didn't quite cross the line and I
thought I got friends to win a date with
you know no time like an orgy of
hardener it was something like the
hiring partner was like driving people
around for a night you know as a charity
ah yeah sort of a license thing yep and
I was blind drunk like double fisting
bottles of wine I was a 25 year old more
you didn't like oh yeah dude that was
like so rotten it was a third mapa
um so double I don't know what I was
drinking though I was hammered and I
thought that's why I got fired but the
real reason is actually because the
senior female partner in the firm
propositioned me and now I did the worst
possible thing I turned her down and
then I told everybody think you might
slept with her I would have been
basically bulletproof and this is what
happened if I yeah if I shut up I'd have
been fine right okay so I ended up
getting fired
it was both things combined I was a
reckless unguided missile I had no
business working in a law firm they were
totally right to fire me
but the real instigating factor was so
what happens what happens next
you're fired mix it then I can work for
my debt oh well it was kind of like a
whole mess I basically got blackballed
from the legal profession because I
wrote my friends an email about it like
about the event the drinking right that
was like Saturday and I'm getting fired
Wednesday so on Monday I wrote this
really funny email send it to my friends
I get fired and of course my friends are
dicks
so they forwarded email to everybody
what year is this this is Oh 2000 2001
not when people forwarding you're like
or this before myspace or anything like
that and the original social media
executive email for huh huh so I get
blackballed from the legal profession
yes everyone gets this email of me
telling a story so I go work for two
real straight-up question but I'm
curious if has ever been asked how much
subconsciously or consciously yeah I
know exactly yeah asking to be lesson no
yeah right nobody's asking the right
question I'm not scared so and I want to
bring value like I'm listening to this
I'm like I'm like this guy right did you
actually know you had this in you to be
like hey do you think you were a
comedian did you think you were a
culture howling what'd you think was
brewing here's the right answers you
understood something was brewing yeah
there's no way you're here and had that
you see where I'm going so we were
talking about sex she went to law school
too and uh like I think being a lawyer
is a terrible job for the most part for
most people okay and I'm pretty
high-energy I'm pretty creative I'm
pretty entrepreneurial I like to do
things indifferent and that's the
opposite of what you have to be if you
have a lawyer you're just following
rules and ER someone else's paper my
wife and I think I realize that but I
quite honestly dude I don't think I have
the courage to do anything about it or
the emotional maturity even recognize
that yeah so that's where the
unconscious stuff comes in it's like I'm
gonna act out and force them you have to
do something that I don't get her to do
myself seriously 25 yeah no way
and so what happens next I'm not working
my dad he owns a restaurant company in
South Florida socks you know a lot of a
I come from a rough smilers out of my
family's restaurants that's cool yeah
and um then he he ends up firing me it's
months later my old dad fires me for the
family mighty my dad fired my sister my
actually here's an unknown fact my dad
fired me once I was fired by Sasha this
is a real thing I who worked every
minute of my goddamn life once asked in
my senior year to leave at 7:00 p.m.
which was considered early in our day to
go to a graduation party and my dad said
I wasn't committed to the mural Roger
and my own high school bread I would say
I work every day of high school every
weekend every summer vacation like this
whole like this weekend I spent time
with my family we just have we got a
place and we're like I'm like I finally
understand why people love summer so
much because I never had once in seventh
grade my dad fired me so I understand
being fired by your bed yeah well and by
the way I won that battle and Dad you
know it because I then was pumped cuz I
had two days for free to myself in the
summer I was like wait a minute
like I hung out my friends I played with
the long baseball card show I was not
asking to come back and then my dad had
to say you could cook and my dad said
I'm picking you what do you say walked
in my room he's like I'll see you at
7:00 in the morning I'm like dude I
think this is a difference of you and me
I would get fired for that stuff I got
fired because I was a jackass
look I got fired for totally legit
reasons I think the long long story
basically is that my dad had a bunch of
clowns working for him and I was 25 and
stupid and interesting anything about
the world so I thought all right my
dad's got a great business I know I can
expand this and I went in I told the
clowns working for him that they weren't
good enough to work there and I was
going to get them fired and I was gonna
build business yeah this is my social
intelligence at the time and of course
these people all know office politics
and my dad much better than I do right
now
but I still think it doesn't matter I'm
bright and my name's on the door
obviously my dad's gonna pick me so then
I also give them all the information in
the world by doing things like um you
know I'll meet some girl to write and do
it real quick like just because I think
is the important thing for them trying
to bring them value again you think
subconsciously
yes well so here's what happens let me
the question that's burning inside of me
did you know that you had this kind of
like personality that you that you
literally think that like do you
understand the internet well enough at
that point but do you think that you
were going to become famous or a
personality the god-honest answer is um
I'm most like blew me away I really
honestly mostly lucked into a lot of
stuff I'm lucked into a lot of
opportunities I picked up those
opportunities and busted my ass once I
did you think that you had a likeable
personality two goons and bros no
because I was no different than my nine
friends liked to do the guy's a brain so
don't feel it didn't feel in the terms
of intelligence or social ability or
funny I was dead in the middle of X
right a lot of friends were funny yeah
I'm just the duke who wrote it all down
and the reason I wrote it down so like I
did fine so is that what the book was
this they were stories that the first
like eight stories in the book are they
also so my friends their emails and so
actually now real quick and I know we
have questions gonna this be more of an
interview in the askgaryvee show but I'm
enjoying it plus it's like eight years
of pent up friendships I just want to
get some context um how did the book
deal happen
so I actually um I tried to get
published so I wrote these emails of my
friends about all the stories that dumb
things I did they got me fired like
having a girl yeah I hooked up with some
girl in the bathroom when I was on shift
and have these sort of things yeah so it
gave all the people in munition to talk
that about me and my dad he fires me and
I write emails about all the dumb things
I'm doing drinking hooking up with these
girls in South Florida and those emails
my friends like that's the funniest this
is the funny stuff I've ever read like
you're not that funny in person but
you're very funny email were you getting
an amazing like high from the feedback
of your friends reality show it wasn't
about writing it was about making my
friends live I never occurred to me that
anyone would think these emails were
funny outside of my nine front right and
they're like so
after I get fired from both jobs one of
my friends is like look man you don't
you're not good at anything else but
you're really good at right
these emails right this is what you
should do and it never occurred to me to
be a writer at that point so I sent my
emails every agent every publisher this
is a one Leto one every E or maybe early
o to every one I could find
100% without exception rejection and
most people ignored it and the people
that responded were like really rude
yeah Locke's mostly ringing dick face
well most of it was just more magic yeah
there were three or four like
personalized you're the worst writer
I've everybody
Kyodai I generally hate you like deers
Doug sighing you all right I got into
writing to keep your heart come out
really for real and so because the
publisher so after that I ended up
getting this dude jeremy ruby Strauss
who worked at Kensington which was a
small publish still is kind of a small
publisher he found my blog loved it
thought are you funny something there's
a little piece there you started putting
these you started putting this article
so you know what I'm trying to show Jeff
this is such a business show what I'm
more fascinated by and I is you clearly
knew what was happening with the current
state of the internet during that period
of time you're doing email so that you
know we're getting forwarded you just
went into a blog if you're talking about
Oh 102 there what are you blogging a
blogger or type a geocities Jeep so like
you know so this is the part that I
think is most interesting to baby bad
because Ryan wood right so so to that
point to me always thinking about how to
extract value bro such a big portion
knows who you are read the book things
of that nature but so many don't write
to me again here's another person that
executed in a platform that was
underrated attention and used it to
expand the thing I get rejected by all
the gatekeepers right this is still a
102 I get rejected by all the rental
world's gonna do so that's in the
internet was kind of Geocities starting
to blow up so I was like well I'll just
put my stories up for free and everyone
literally laughed at me because that's
just like how could you do that you have
to charge for writing and I'm like I got
nowhere else to publish distribution and
then it blew up like it took about four
long months it was called Tucker Marx
calm or something matter right that's
what I'm in and so like this girl ended
up suing me because I wrote about her it
was all true do you say her name oh yeah
it was all 100% true okay and it was a
big First Amendment case she got this a
temporary restraining order issued it
was like prior restraint in long long
story but blew my side up and then after
that it got all this traffic and I won
the case because I was telling the truth
that I was right and then publishers all
came back to me and then the guy ended
up going with was the one who really
built the best relationship right yeah
and then then book didn't come out until
six that was 203 maximum emotions yeah
it was a lot of [ __ ] it's just
longer than mainstream publishing all
that stuff but the cool thing is I built
my email list the whole time not even
trying I didn't really understand it I
just had the email list because it's the
easiest way to reach people that's how
you started and so by the time the book
came out I had fifty hundred thousand
people so I sold six thousand copies the
first week no I literally zero reviews
no one talked about this book anywhere I
hit the New York Times bestseller list
out of nowhere right and I was the first
my book was the very first one to go
blog to bestseller very first I mean did
he get a lot of coverage for that not
really that was still back when media
that was you know still they're like who
are these blog people gonna get but they
don't matter that exists this is when o
6 January will sell sand right well now
why would you be started there was you
know yeah I know I remember your one
show was blowing up about the sign take
my mind was you were just in a different
there all these people have different
kind of finding their ways into things
kind of by accident
yeah um yeah and so then book took off
book kind of took off and then went down
and then built by word-of-mouth after
that like people credit me for all I've
done all these marketing things like oh
it's so smart I honestly don't think
anything that's that matter I think the
fact that I wrote a great book that a
lot of people loved and told their
friends about and you reckon surely your
first book you've written have more than
one four four before in that genre yeah
like the New York Times call it fraud
tire which it makes no sense because I
wasn't in a fraternity yeah but whatever
and then now you know like I retired
from that because I you yeah you can't
act like your twenties in their 40s
that's right alright India that was fun
yeah
Taylor he's gonna ask questions we're
gonna get to shoot Taylor asks what's
been the biggest key to your creative
process and ability to tell stories that
connect people yeah that's a great
question so um the way I always frame it
and I think it's I started this way by
accident and I've just stayed this way
is I started writing because I was
trying to make nine people live right
you know like this saying that if you if
you want to change the world you've got
to change our one more start with either
yourself or one person yes I think the
same thing is true for storytelling if
you can't make a small group of people
laugh or react in whatever way you're
again you can't get a big group to do it
right and so every time I write I always
think uh consciously in my head who is
my audience why do they care so super
interesting I suck you know you guys
have heard Sally Arkansas uh his world
would be like Rik polo like I imagine
these people that I think there's way
more than nine of them you're nine
buddies represent twenty-two percent of
dudes in America and that's why it's a
big audience and that's where I think
about here right even the way I
interviewed in the first 10-15 minutes
here I'm like okay I know who's watching
right I whether black white green alien
their entrepreneurial they care about
things and like as I was listening and
getting more context to what I generally
knew like this guy want and did well in
books I'm like wait a minute this guy
knew this guy knew with email forwarding
and blogging very early again always
trying to drill home for them that white
space so that's what I do I reverse
engineer what is the biggest felt why
might be TV worked because I was like
because I spend ten years in a wine shop
and watch people come in and people that
were like Duke law lawyers super and
familiar if I want super it's like alpha
males walking in this from million I
mean about like like Brayton I'm like
God my world is so douchey so
suppressive in the same way think about
entrepreneurship right now like I just
want to empower people to be like who
gives a [ __ ] what people just do it and
like so anyway reverse engineers very
similar go ahead Jonathan wants to know
last time I heard the name Tucker Max I
finished I hope they serve beer and how
Lots has changed would you do it all
again
of course I mean I've got you here right
I would try and do a lot of things
differently but what's the number thing
in a no-bullshit way because I'm doing
this because I think you know there's no
other way for me to be beautiful but but
knowing that like again back to I was
happy when you're like eh like I want to
go to like a place with like I know
you've been on so many different things
like like in a very [ __ ] real way
like what's the one core thing you think
you would do different um I would
realize a lot earlier that it's not
about me right now even though I'm
really good at doing that with my art
yeah like my stories even though they're
about me if you read all for my books
reps you don't know very much about me
at all you know a lot about things that
happen to me and you've laughed a lot
you've really enjoyed it but I don't I
don't burden the reader with nonsense
about me because people reading my books
want to be in our team they're not
trying to learn deep about my emotions
whatever right but in the way I meet
business decisions early in my career I
was arrogant and stupid and I made most
emotional yen to leverage um so there
was a movie made about my first book
that movie should have done a hundred
million or more the box-office and it
did like 2 million and because I mean
because of my arrogance my hubris and be
one is impose certain things he had
creative control over yeah man yeah it
really was like writing is a very
singular art right it's also like I
don't have anyone else's help to be a
crush a book to make a movie it's a
whole group of people and even the
smallest movie ever is still baby peep
and you went into that place of like
look it's a lot of this is like right
holding tight and um and I did because
that I picked the wrong director I
picked most of the wrong production you
picked yes people know I would if I pick
me you might it might have been just my
vision which would have been better than
what it was it became a Frankenstein
yeah it was Half Price
yeah exactly and and I picked a lot of
people who told me what I wanted to hear
early on but had their own agendas sure
and I was blind to it and I was so
caught up in myself my own ego that I
screwed up a really massive opportunity
for myself
sure it was game changer that and that
goes for a Hondo different things well I
know it's funny people always ask me my
biggest mistakes and I was trying to
come up with something because I don't
like to think about my mistakes I
actually like disrespect my mistakes
it's a very
like I recognize them but I give them no
[ __ ] energy like really I'm like cool
mistake you go over there right but no
question my biggest mistakes have been
the things that I passed on and haven't
done no like it was interesting to think
about like that and that happened right
but like I could have been a judge on
Top Chef I could have done all these
other business shows like there's a lot
of things you know that I always think
about the things that I haven't done
investing right I've done well but
passing on uber twice was the clear one
I know to everybody but everybody had me
that all right let's go
Daniella asks I'm an immigrant with an
entrepreneurial dream all my parents
care about is college which I hate any
advice
that's tough um did you get pressured to
be a good student no I came from one of
those families were just expected and
but I'm worried there was no even in
writing so I I came from working you
weren't even a conversation no no no it
just wasn't even conversation I came
from one of those weird families where
high expectations were always there but
my parents were not very good at being
parents and so I was basically ignored
so I kind of raised myself but
unconsciously yes it links no only child
child yeah I think unconsciously I
understood at a very young age that the
adults were never going to help me no
one was coming to help me and so I had
to learn like the system as its
presented to you is [ __ ] and the
only gift they gave me about being
terrible parents is that I was never
fooled by the lies that the system tells
you like school right I learned how to
hack the system you feel like early on
you made a decision that you weren't
getting value from your parents and thus
every grown-up during your youth you
looked in a cynical point of view not
just the grown-ups but the actual
systems of the grown-ups all operate in
and represent whether it's work or
whether it's corporations or school it's
not that everything is invalid it's just
that the the face that they present is
never the reality it's so interesting I
on the other hand had an amazing parents
but came to that same realization that
our young age uh yeah I mean those are
interesting different paths to get to
that place so that's really dictated my
life where I was like oh my god I'm not
this and like I've got another cheese I
was in fourth grade for sure I'm like
crap I got another nine years of eating
this [ __ ] Oh see you got out early I'm
like how do i how do I break this system
how do I have to to make it work for me
yeah you decided to win within it I
decided to literally go on vacation
because I realized subconsciously I was
never gonna be on vacation again you
know what's funny is I think if we're
talking about unconscious uh I think I I
realized I had no other support you had
great parents yeah I have this other
world I can go into I knew by year like
I need this right I think I win it this
system so that I have because I don't
have anyone what's the person's name um
Daniella I'm gonna give you very
difficult advice I really think you need
to have the most honest and truthful
conversation you've ever had with your
parents and then react to their reaction
I think if you really I don't know if
you've ever gone there all the way we're
like this is really ruining me like like
not like hey mom and dad I don't like
school it's like I'm suffocating and
truly believe my life will not be as
good as it could be if I go down this
path watching your parents reaction to
those words verbatim would be will give
you a really good indication because
then you get to understand are your
parents wired to really value you and
what you have what where you are and
what's in your best interest from your
point of view or do they really care
about their point of view and what their
child's success means to them I've
become very fascinated you might have
better insight this I grew up in a way
where I didn't know like the fancy world
and so like bumper stickers of colleges
on cars or like like parents telling
kids to take on college debt at better
schools wait a minute that's in their
interest cuz they get to tell their
friends that University Chicago is real
fancy I'd be sure to Punk to Misha and
Xander went there Lea I'm like holy crap
that's interesting well so I think it's
fantastic advice let me just add one
sort of way to frame this so when you go
talk to your parents I think the way to
frame it is not here's my argument
because you're never going to convince
someone with a compelling argument
rarely what you want to do is start by
asking them questions do you care about
me
how much do you care what do you really
care about what matters the most to you
and what they're going to say is we care
about you being happy we care about you
finding yourself in about you whatever
right now
get them to commit to that and then say
alright if you really do care about me
and you really do it doesn't matter to
you that I'm this happy I'm going to
tell you I don't want to go to school
because it makes me very or college
makes me very unhappy and trying these
other things for a year or two is going
to make me much happier it will you
support me as I do something at least
four and you can even find it as
temporary give me a year to support me
and if it doesn't work I'm happy to go
back to call and support me mentally
right like the financial writer probably
what I'm not I know that emotional I
know that I want to I want to frame that
up for people and I would say the other
thing like look like there's casualties
of war and your parents are not going to
be around for your casualties of what
they think is in your better interest
and versus you I mean the gift that I
was given that I really wish I could
you know like stick into every goddamn
person is the audacity and confidence at
a very young age to just say this is the
deal huh
like like that independence is
incredible and like and that's hard for
a lot of people but like if you're
asking me on this show like to me
actions speak louder than words if you
publicly tweeted this and asked me and
wanted me to answer you're just looking
for somebody to push you over the finish
line many of you are watching this and
think it but would never come you to
publicly and fear that your parents
would see it
you're clearly this close and you need
somebody to nudge you I'm willing to
nudge you I mean I really do think there
are real moments in time to say go [ __ ]
yourself mom and dad the end it's real
and it's real not from a bad cool and
growing out from a this is it like this
is a crossroads and a lot of people get
forced into doing their are kids with
massive debt because they wanted appease
their parents and they lose they lose
because they kick their 20s and don't
take the risk/reward things they should
be doing to just pay down the debt and
they wake up at 34 and they just finally
are even from something that they
decided at 17 because their parents push
100
in their paint now that I've got older
and I'm spending time appearance in
their parents vested interest of vanity
that's the worst
let's do one more because I gotta go to
speaking parents I gotta go run to
Misha's school and hey Gary I'm the
Steven from Columbia I am 10 years old
my question is if I want to make videos
about cars motorcycles because I love
you or my life in general
I mean blocks because I love it too what
should I do
because you say that you were so hard
until 30 and you say that people were
suspect your for your actions
I dream being a successful entrepreneur
and I want respect too but how virtual
resource or I saw work in silence I mean
knowing camera now in social media
what should I do Gary please I want to
go Arlene I Love You Man
anybody in this planet is like you sorry
for my English head you despising keep
pushing and grandchildren or anything
right even editing this with a little
subtitles on what you see but you see
Stephen real quick I'll jump in and
Tucker please add to anything you can to
this uh I want to give you a definition
I said that I built a business until I
was thirty thirty-two and then I talked
about business stuff instead of being a
20 year old giving business advice
you're a Content producer you're talking
about your opinions that's different if
you were giving advice as a 10 year old
a 20 or 30 year old about building a
business or building a motorcycle
business or things of that nature that's
very different than you pontificating
giving your two cents
adding to culture social commentating so
what I want to give you a definition is
my whole weight here 32 talk to the
world if you're going to give advice I
do think it should be predicated on
something advice you know giving your
two cents we're all entitled to our
opinions social commentating we're all
entitled to that making videos and
commentating I think the journey of your
life and your thoughts and those things
are super fine you clearly I mean I
would push very hard when I just saw
gave me a nice little tingle keep
pounding produce content use all the
platforms use your youth and native
ability on this
world that we now live in musically
snapchat produced for all mediums get it
out there yeah I mean it just seems to
me like he's got a lot of charisma right
now great totally great content producer
so then ask yourself what we talked the
very first question what audience do you
want to talk to and what do they care
about and there's a lot of young guys I
bet in Colombia who care about cars and
motorcycles and that stuff if you become
the guy who speaks to all of them that
puts you in a great position to start a
lot of different business or I can tell
that's exactly right where I can tell
you nothing there's a lot of people that
are actually just curious what youth
life and culture in Colombia's like I
was watching that like looking the
background like I learned something
about what the kids like I actually
think just your life is actually
interesting to so many people and nobody
can you know if you're not in Colombia
you can't produce content around
Colombia and so use your advantages that
so many people think are disadvantage
act Lee my man super let's go you get
you get a parting shot here anything you
want to ramble on and then a question of
the day a question this is a great focus
group opportunity some insight that you
may be looking for it there's a ton of a
spinal needle yes you every guest gets
asked the question day there's a ton of
aspiring I mean hundreds of people of
emailed me about writing a book and
things that nature I know you guys are
jamming on that um so any question about
that already know or any insight well I
was looking on Twitter right before you
came in how much people ask questions
about writing books we actually wrote a
book that details our entire process
like the higher us is really expensive
it's at 20 grand
yeah for book in a box but we wrote a
book that tells exactly what we let step
we link that up so far so just go to
book and a voxcom slash Gary yeah your
fans can go there and then they get a
free copy of the book that they want it
and literally it's step by step process
to use our method to write their own
book it takes more time than if you hire
us but it's the exact same templates
everything smart again data in exchange
for good content there you go mark we're
gonna bomb song SlashGear good man
thanks for and now why should you ask
any question any question ah silly made
one there's all right we'll see you're
so I've been I got a smart audience is
good at media so anyone who's interested
go look at our site book on our box comm
what do you think we're doing
wrong in terms of messaging or marketing
reanalysis right our our audience are
people who have great ideas for books
who can monetize those ideas like
coaches consultants CEOs entrepreneurs
people who've had success what are we
doing right and wrong to talk to those
people any ideas you have please send to
me Tucker at book in a box I'd love to
hear the next webinar thank you you keep
asking questions we'll keep answering
them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video no
it'll be it's here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my youtube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys click this that's right use
that